[Music]
sundays are just like their it gets to
about five o'clock and songs of praise I
hate absolutely hate songs of praise
comes on and I just think that's it the
weekend's over
I've done nothing and normally I reach
for my phone and text at least five of
my friends and say you know what are you
doing you know now being Julia and one
daughter you know we haven't got this
Sunday lunch family thing so what do you
have the last Sunday lunch what did you
eat tuna sandwich for something lunch
for Sunday lunch Julie s from teenager
up to mid-20s I made dinner I hope her
dinner then I got married to master chef
who took over the kitchen for ten years
free and didn't let me in no really
and then when we divorced couldn't
remember what to do so go your husband
your ex-husband don't like for this one
yeah well no pickle t+ inside here
that's it inside your cupboard what's he
doing in there ah what is he doing in
there well well it was it was saving me
buying a takeaway jerk seasonings ah we
should put that one next to him oh yeah
you know that sits there nice and
comfortably I like the idea of your
friends coming around I like the idea of
something that they can share they can
go in the middle of the table and they
can all dive in yeah that's perfect
Tyler in terms of you know usually
involves rice rice and chicken yeah
what's wrong with rice well it's cooking
it can't you make disasters no no no but
I mean with the stock water in fact and
things like chorizo and stuff on it
cooks yourself
300 grams of squid and training the
grams of prawns please thank you for
Sunday lunch last week at the table
see
[Music]
Tyler was that's how you able never okay
Sarita just not that nice spicy and it
actually flavors the rice is about the
same time good get hold of the chiles
[Music]
they are really hot and I want to use
this sort of the whole chili rather than
the seeds slice it down like that a nice
thing about starting the tree they're
down at the onions was that nice
romantic moment when you're not crying
over a phone bill your client over at
Pilar are using chicken but you also
make this with fish or rabbit adding
sherry gives it a deeper flavor what
that evaporated what I want you to do is
put the rice in and this is where you
always get a little bit confusing
sprinkle the Pilar
mix all in no one to get that rice
nicely color okay there you go
so next time what you do is to get the
saffron what does this do the saffron
gives it an amazing color and gives a
really nice flavor as well and to finish
off prawns squid and clams so far so
good
yes you're doing good
it'd be Pepi they're the back the
Masters will bring that down and there
we are look quite a fit for a king and
then my dear lady we're ready to roll
[Music]
ladies times as I sat around a table
like this I'm slightly intimidated I'm
gonna ban texting okay no more Texas
under something afternoon because you'll
be here device however if you can't find
file arise then choose the long gray you
have to promise me something today yeah
that once a week yes that you will start
cooking something from scratch from
scratch truth go make a decision to go
shopping with my list yeah I'm gonna
moat around that supermarket avoiding
all the pre-packed precooked free
ready-made destructions and I'm
definitely definitely going to cook the
aubergines with fresh tomato mix them
with onion and cumin and then puree mmm